it was like kind of certain yeah just
I'd be an atheist for the rest of my
life like I don't believe in God right
maybe you've seen over the last like one
year or so that I've really started to
consider this more and more to the point
now that I'm literally reading the Quran
my mom used to make me read that when I
was a child and you know I never really
wanted to I always like struggled or
whatever and now I've actively started
reading it by my own accord
welcome back to the three Muslims if you
guys remember a few months ago we did a
stream with Hamza
and we you know kind of addressed a lot
of things about his religion his views
on Islam and everything like that so
where are you in terms of coming back to
Islam
seems like it's a uh
a process like it's not something I
could just like jump into I can't
imagine it's something that'll be quick
uh with everything you guys are saying
with for example praying and then today
here's what we find out
Jeffrey is a racist for some reason he
just hates people who believes in God
now of course there's some normal
atheist but Jeffrey is a hater he spends
his time on Reddit and in the YouTube
comment section swearing at people God
doesn't exist
come on Jeffrey people are entitled to
their own beliefs Adonis
when you think of Adonis what kind of
man do you think he would be would he be
a Reddit atheist or would he be a Godly
Man wouldn't a man like Adonis raise his
children in a way to fear God wouldn't
he prefer to have a woman whose whole
Community believes in God and follows a
structured system to live their lives by
Adonis is a man of values and he gets
that from his religion I hated being
brown skinned I hated identifying as a
Muslim I was born in Pakistan and we
moved to the UK when I was just a few
years old and my parents raised me to be
a Muslim and by the time I got a few
years old and 9 11 had happened all I
saw on the TV was issues with brown
people as a young child it became
confirmed in my mind that being Brown
was a bad thing being Muslim meant that
I was a terrorist it was a source of
ridicule and bullying in school until
eventually I started adopting more of
this like white British culture but I
never really fit in with the people here
I made jokes about my own race and my
own religion and you know I was like the
self-deprecating little Pakistani guy
who's like making racist jokes about
brown people and everything and like
calling myself a terrorist just to try
and make the white boys laugh when I
look back now like you know it's Korean
it's kind of annoying when I think of
that little [ __ ] version of me but I
also just see like this young boy who
was so pressured by the society and the
media around him that convinced him that
being Brown was a bad thing that being
religious was a bad thing that being
Muslim meant that you're a terrorist and
that's all I saw every single day on the
TV every single day here in the news and
everything that okay brown people are
bad and you know about Muslims and
terrorists and so of course I didn't
want to identify with that when there
would be like some kind of terrorist
attack I would literally personally feel
shame and I would rarely want to deviate
away from those people and act extra
white next to my friends I abandoned my
race My Religion my faith my God and I
indulged in the pleasures of the West
the degeneracy that's available here you
know there's those Temptations whether
you're a religious man or not there's
those temptations that you will have
those desires promiscuity of [ __ ]
these girls here of watching porn taking
drugs of partying and drinking alcohol
enjoying yourself I did all of that you
can literally see my journey through
these hundreds of videos that I've made
you can see that this is real that I
indulged in that lifestyle we have
hundreds of videos of me
I enjoyed that lifestyle all that the
Godless West has to offer and here I am
today in front of you saying
it wasn't that great why is it that you
see men like Andrew Tate who again has
experienced like all that the West has
to offer all these hedonistic Pleasures
convert into Islam because once you've
fulfilled all of these Primal desires of
yours you're left with this spiritual
numbness this emptiness but then also
this paranoia this fear of what may
arise when you are a Godless man now if
you're watching this and you're thinking
this is weird and wait why it sounds a
preaching religion to us I don't want
you to feel like you're not welcome so
much I'm not religious religious not yet
I've been atheist for literally most of
my life and only just in the last few
months have I realized like something
has got to change now Tate has recently
just come out and said that he's Muslim
and he's a man that I respect I hope
that this video doesn't seem like I'm
just imitating him or copying him
because this is a major life decision
that we're talking about but he's a man
that I respect and what he's gave the
arguments for and against the leading in
God for and against being religious it
makes total sense to me that we are
always going to worship something I'm
gonna say this again you are always
worshiping something if you're an
atheist which I am so I'm not being
hateful or anything but I am too but if
you're an atheist and you don't believe
in God you're still worshiping something
you still have some kind of God okay
it's not a religious God it's not the
god from the Bible it's not but you
still worship something
you know I carried this concept I hope
this makes sense I carried this concept
in my mind okay you're always worshiping
something religious people worship a God
and a holy book atheists what do they
worship what do atheists scream and go
crazy about what do people in like this
Godless country I'm in the UK what do
people worship here Brothers gang
members if you're uncertain about that
you can search on YouTube right now
search for some rapper and write concert
at the end of it and you will see all
these people crazy crazy oh my god oh
that's the guy oh at least
he is their God when you live in a
Godless country you're still being given
people to worship now the issue is the
person that you're worshiping isn't this
holy Almighty power it's not like this
force of good it's this random [ __ ]
Thug degenerate I was like kind of
certain yeah just I'd be an atheist for
the rest of my life like I don't believe
in God right maybe you've seen over the
last like one year or so that I've
really started to consider this more and
more to the point now that I'm literally
reading the Quran my mom used to make me
read that when I was a child and you
know I never really wanted to I always
like struggled or whatever and now I've
actively started reading it by my own
accord and I called my mom two days ago
and told her and I just saw like the
biggest smile on her face when I told
her that I started reading you know our
holy book and she just got like so happy
she told me it was the right thing she
told me of this you know this was the
way forward right here right now you
either fully believe me you agree with
me and you're like yeah this is amazing
he'll be one of our brothers that's
amazing and that's awesome but maybe
you're watching this right now you're
just feeling weird and think okay this
guy is preaching to us I don't care
about religion religion's not important
trust me when I say I felt exactly the
same way for all of my life maybe you're
not there just yet but there will be a
point as you keep advancing yourself
improvements especially when you start
looking into like The Wider scale of
things you start really investigating
why countries rise and fall you start
investigating the kind of country that
you want to raise your children and then
you start to realize that countries that
eventually give up their culture their
values and their religion end up getting
[ __ ] decimated by another country
that's kept their hardcore values and
you see a strong successful man being
silenced being hate on being called
toxic where do you see them all go they
don't stay in these [ __ ] countries
anymore you see Tate just move over like
you know he was started in UK then he
moved over to Romania then he's moved to
Dubai I'm going to Dubai you see Iman
move to Dubai bro everyone's moving East
every smart rich person is moving East
and literally they're all moving to a
Muslim country why think about that
these guys are probably Your Role Models
all of your role models are moving to a
Muslim country and all of the broke guys
are still going out to the pub and you
see them like lying down on the floor
like you're the gritty dirty floor at
the end of the night I was like oh I'm
so [ __ ] like oh I had too many jager
bombs like you know there's countries
because of religion that totally
inhibits especially the sexual just
freedom but just the sexual freedom of
their young people Islam restricts that
Islam restricts the sexual freedom of
the young people there you only get to
have sex and you only get to experience
the opposite sex once you're about to
get married and guess what happens then
a young Muslim guy and a young Muslim
since they're restricted from being able
to you know date or have sex or anything
they're focused on being productive good
citizens in a right like in an enforced
Islamic country people go through the
school system focused on their studies
and so they produce some top level
doctors and engineers in their country
get stronger here what happens through
the school system here if you're in the
UK or the US what happens during school
you're busy thinking oh has she replied
oh did he just [ __ ] me and now he's
not replying anymore think about how
much of their brain power is being taken
away by the openness of the sexual
Revolution the other kids are having sex
at age let's see India do you really
think they're focused on their studies
do you really think this country is
going to produce like the best workers
that it could do 100 this sounds
contradictive coming from someone who's
indulged in the degeneracy here yo this
is a case of me experiencing these
things [ __ ] around enjoying the drug
culture the party culture here then
transforming and telling you don't do it
and you can say to yourself wait but
this guy's done it so how is he telling
me not to do it the only way that I
could tell you not to do these things
like for example to not continue playing
video games to maybe maybe reconsider
being an atheist maybe don't take drugs
maybe don't be so sex obsessed with the
women here because I've done them myself
and I'm speaking from experience how
interesting is that that you are seeing
the rise of strong men who are from
Western countries who have indulgent
every pleasure that the degenerate
Western world has to offer and you are
seeing these men take a big step away
from the Western World and tell you like
it's not even that great you're
literally seeing guys who've indulged in
everything and they're telling you that
it's not that great now I'll speak
directly to the Muslims who are watching
this the young Muslims who might have
some kinds of Temptations right now I
can emphasize with you especially if you
live in countries like this and all
you're seeing is just ass every day ass
on Tick Tock ass on social media your
school teacher is a stripper because
that's oh well you know sex workers your
school teachers got [ __ ] only fans
these days oh man you know oh we've got
to support sex workers as a young Muslim
and you're being sold sex and the
Temptation will keep increasing
hopefully you can see a man like me
maybe a man like Tay and just think
these guys have indulged in that and
they're literally still telling you that
it's not worth this even I've started
reading the Quran and maybe you should
too
I was having a call with uh one of my
clients before this and you know we were
talking about you know some struggles
and hardships you know growing up here
and kind of finding nihilism and just
you know what's the point of Islam If
eventually Islam ends up not being real
what if there's no God what if you would
die and it's there's no angel of death
and it kind of gives you a little bit of
an existential crisis and I was telling
him I was like okay
and then I was like so so like what's
your fear and he's like what if what if
I could have just lived like a little
bit more done a little bit more Haram
you know so to speak just to make me
feel more alive
what am I really sacrificing all this
for and I asked him and I said
I want you to understand one thing bro
Hedonism is a black hole
every single time you tell yourself okay
I know what I'm doing but just one more
time you know one more not one more
joint one more sip I promise I won't
need any more after just one more and
then I'll be good I'll quench my thirst
every single time you tell yourself that
as soon as you do it I'm sure you might
feel that way but then a day later
a week later a month later could even be
a few hours later you're going to be
ready to do it again
for another one more time
and I told them you'll never
ever put out this Flame
um a scholar is asked
I think about eight years and the AP is
like oh how are you gonna feel
when you die and you realize that it was
all fake that like there's no Jannah
there's no
it was all fake that there's no God
stuck for Allah
and then the scholar was like oh I'm
gonna feel a whole lot better than you
when you realize that it was real when
you're going straight to jahannam that's
taking a step back bro because last we
talked to him he said he feels this
thing blocking him I don't know if I
don't know if we should have gotten our
boy rokio bro I don't know if if that's
what we should have done but what we do
know is he literally said there was a
physical literal block that was
prevented anything from looking into the
Quran
I think bro it was just programming
from what he had heard in the past and
like it was still like his his reality
his experience just hadn't it just
hadn't linked up yet with the
you know not having this block anymore
but alhamdulillah like you see it now
this this block isn't there
clearly this block isn't there he's
acknowledged what it was what the block
was what he was experiencing like
perhaps what was holding him back all
this time and now he's reading the Quran
so all we can do is make love for him
bro
but man brother that's that's beautiful
that he's reading the Quran now and it
wouldn't bro what are the odds this is
where you have to like kind of reflect
on this and just see how Allah has just
this perfect plan of everything
because
he's close or I don't know how close he
is to uh Andrew Tate but I know that he
was definitely looking at Andrew Tate
and like what Andrew Tate does and then
he sees Andrew Tate go from this life
into being Muslim so that's already kind
of like in his uh Forefront of his mind
and he's as he's seeing that
he sees him to take basically going over
to the east moving to Dubai and he's
he's living in the UK he had experience
what he experienced he said in one of
his videos he saw someone get uh robbed
right out uh like
a few meters away from his his apartment
or something like this and then I'm sure
at some point he starts thinking like
okay we're better what better place can
I move and then he goes to Dubai and in
Dubai you know okay Dubai is like a real
flashy right but he's in Dubai and in
Dubai you have the head then
so now he's hearing me at Dan every
single day he's hearing via Dan he's in
a Muslim land where he's more exposed to
Muslims so now instead of having that
narrative that programming that's saying
all these bad things about Muslims well
now it's like it's kind of breaking that
programming apart because he's seeing
the Muslims firsthand he's hearing the
Adan he's seeing how beautiful it is
he's seeing how safe this country is not
this one I'm not into fight right now
but he's seen that for himself and it's
just like subhanallah like Allah made
all that happened to her now
this man
is actually
no longer blood he's opened up and he's
reading the Quran so again like let's
just let's make Dua for this man because
everything he said in that video
is the truth I did want to wrap it up by
giving some type of a just a message to
humza some advice to homes or some
pointers to harms or because I
understand it's at this point where
some people make it forward and some
people don't and this is not to me you
know make me pessimistic or anything
like that and or set him up for failure
or anything like that may Allah guide
him fully to the truth and be firm ten
toes down with Huck I mean and that's
all I want but it's at this time bro
when there is a danger that lurks bro
there is some people that don't want to
fully let go of this programming that's
side by side while they read the Quran
what do they do bro
we had a friend like this may Allah got
him to Islam but side by side they they
watch other YouTubers that don't like
Islam they hate Islam they're
islamophobes but they have an agenda
they need patreon content you know
you got to come with an empty cup
or a half full cup why don't you
elaborate on that what does that mean
because a lot of people are like why is
this guy holding a coffee mug
if I'm coming to you
and you got some coffee and I want some
coffee I want to try this coffee you're
telling me about this coffee you've got
you're like man This coffee's so good
bro like the aroma the flavor bro you
just bang like it pops in your mouth bro
I'm like yo I want some of that and
you're like yeah yeah here here let me
give you some if I come to you and this
cup is full
I can't try yours
I I it's not I can't tell you I might
get like a very tiny like hint of it
mixed into what I already have if mine
is a half full even then like I'm not
trying it 100 I'm not receiving a
hundred percent the coffee that you have
but if I come to you with an empty cup
and you pour that coffee in this cup boy
I'm gonna taste a hundred percent of
that their coffee
and that's the whole point man people
got to come into it with an empty Cup in
order to receive the message fully
damn I think that was perfectly Perfect
Analogy bro I love about it I think you
I couldn't have explained it better bro
Miller bless you for that and that
that's that's it bro because you see
these these groups on on the internet on
YouTube this whole industry this whole
demographic this whole economy bro them
getting patreon money them getting
supporters and super chats from other
people that just hate Islam because
they're just too programmed
they're not going to get food on the
table if they don't get subs and
donations and all of that so they need
to keep making these videos slandering
Islam taking things out of context lies
just like mainstream media so it's in
and of ourselves
in our best interest that we come into
it with an empty cup as much as we can
the brother on those side
so this is going to be probably the
first advice and primary not primary the
the priority in what you should do and
keep in the Forefront of your mind when
you're coming into it
and it's easy to you know start like
that but then a couple chapters and
you're like oh but I remember someone
said this about this chapter this verse
and get lost in the sauce
how does it die
inshallah bro inshallah we will we'll
see you out there bro let's see you out
there at some point
inshallah if you even watch this video
inshallah we can get that in person
podcast sometime we'd love to we'll come
to Dubai make it happen
that's number one bro I got one more
point because we're gonna keep it too
much
yeah and the number two bro once you
understand that Islam is the truth the
Quran is truth there's no doubt there's
no fiber in your being where you're like
you know what this is it and Anna's been
through it because he read the Quran and
you know I don't know if you finish the
whole thing but he came to a point where
he's like you know what this is it like
I know I know like being Muslim is the
only thing that matters now
and there's all these thoughts that you
might have in your mind like okay once I
start I gotta pray five times a day now
oh and then I go to fast forward oh I
gotta like cut some people off or
distance myself from some practices or
not do certain holidays and one after
another after another all these thoughts
are just gonna bombard you uh once
you have some advice from your your
personal life for what you did did you
do did you try to become the perfect
Muslim before taking the shahada or did
you then take the shahada then try to
become the ideal Muslim to the best of
your abilities which one bro tell them
tell them what I told you
when uh before I took my child
so when you were ready for the tattoos
about the tattoos oh bro so you
basically so you all know I know had a
lot of tattoos from jahelia and he asked
me uh bro I want to get my whole body
tattooed and then I'm gonna come to a
slab that way it's not like sitting or
anything like that
stuff
and I was like bro if only it worked
that way
you really think knowing what you know
now about not getting tatted up that you
could still do that you think you're
going to be tried the same as someone
that's ignorant bro
no it's not gonna work like that so then
he's like I bet uh let me at least
finish the Quran and I was like nah bro
what's what's after the Quran you know
just do it there's no prerequisite to
becoming a Muslim involving reading the
Quran bro do you believe in Allah
do you believe in the prophet Islam
who came right
do you believe in the angels that have
given him Revelation which is the fourth
thing the books believe in their
judgment and then predestination these
are the six pillars of Iman and then
obviously we have the five pillars of
Islam Allah you know
fasting zakat and Hajj if you can do all
five of these things if you accept that
these are obligatory these are things
we've got to do their main fundamental
pillars of Islam and the six pillars of
Iman of your belief that's enough for
you to become Muslim
what are we talking to that brother bro
I'm not gonna name his name but he was
joking he's like when the mother the
Christian mother Sony's mom he was like
I believe in God and I believe Prophet
Muhammad was a messenger we should have
been like damn bro that's it cut end the
episode right now she's a Muslim bro
she's a Muslim but all jokes aside it
really doesn't take much you don't need
to like 180 your life before you become
a Muslim and you have paralysis behind
us about all these things you take this
step because you know the step is the
only thing that is true in this world
full of lies then you deal with
everything else after
but at least you will not be questioned
on why you didn't take the step after it
has been made clear as day to you
so look I'm gonna tell him this is like
my personal advice if I genuinely had
for my face I also look the journeys
between you
and the Creator so like it's it's very
uh Noble for you to be sharing a lot of
what you share on your social media but
it's genuinely like it's not necessary
because
you have to develop this relationship
you have to get close to the Creator you
have to find the answer you have to find
the truth and this feeling that you have
where it's like you don't want to just
jump right in you don't want to just say
you're Muslim you don't just want to
take the shahada it's it's a few
that does not make sense and the way
that I can actually show you that is
that the more you read the Quran you
will find a part within the Quran where
God says
we will show them the signs Within
and without until they see that this is
the truth
so this feeling that you have these
thoughts that you have that are
maybe blocking you or maybe holding you
back from like fully jumping into it
fully immersing yourself fully letting
go and just going into it
it I want to say it's irrational I want
to say it doesn't make sense I want to
say that it's just
it's just the oil programming it's the
old ways it's it's literally the Jeffrey
inside of you holding you back bro
so inshallah
keep that journey to yourself you know
get closer to God the Creator to
yourself by yourself
as much as you can because I know I know
he's got a lot of people close to him
right now but
um from then and saw Allah bro
he's going to be taking that shahada
real soon bro inshallah Hamza bro if you
made it this far for any weird reason if
you've been watching this video
if if you're ready you're ready if
you're not you're not but regardless
when we come see you bro
we're trying to get that in-person
podcast bro with or without you as a
Muslim bro
we gotta we gotta just have some real
conversations bro because we don't
discriminate over here we got Christians
on the on the channel you know you
already know what the vibe is we'll talk
with anyone we don't discriminate but at
the end of the day we're firm in what we
believe as to be true and what we
believe us to not be right but we're not
gonna just
invalid and you know we're not going to
talk to them there's no hope for them
nothing like that over here so we love
telling other people getting their
points of view getting their view on the
world right
and inshallah we can do the same with
you bro
uh I don't know the Dua that he does bro
what was the one that you you did with
me and Rob
bie
is
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
message and Tower Center to enhance the
Norwegian Tower if you donate to the
schools you will ensure Allah reap the
rewards of thousands of Muslims coming
back to Islam and many of those who
become Dwight and invite Islam so click
the link and donate now and share the
video for extra reward